Et si on pouvait miner les océans pour sauver la
planète et se faire plein de brouzouf au passage ?
Vous avez peut-être entendu parler
du deep sea mining, en bon Français,
l’exploitation minière des fonds marins.
L’ultime frontière. C’est pas encore le cas,
y’a pas d’exploitation en cours, mais ça
risque de se concrétiser dans les mois
ou les années à venir. Donc c’est peut-être
le bon moment pour se documenter là-dessus.
Alors, Jamifle, qu’est-ce que c’est exactement
que ce deep sea mining ? Est-ce que ça vaut le
coup ? Est-ce une opportunité incroyable
ou le prochain scandale écologique ?
Alors d’abord, pourquoi ? Pourquoi je vis,
pourquoi je meurs ? Et surtout, pourquoi
aller 6 pieds sous mer pour extraire des minerais
? Parce qu’y en a pas mal justement ! Regardez ça.
C’est un pré salé (littéralement) où les moutons
sont des nodules polymétalliques. On va jouer.
C’est des boules de pétanque riches en hydroxydes
de manganèse et de fer, qui contiennent aussi
du cuivre, du cobalt et du nickel, et des
traces de lithium, de molybdène et quelques
terres rares. Un bon petit cocktail, quoi.
Ces ingrédients justement, on en a besoin dans
la vie de tous les jours. On s’en sert pour les
téléphones, les transports, les ordinateurs, les
batteries, l’électricité, les miroirs, les bijoux,
les peintures, les produits pharmaceutiques, les
moteurs d’avion, la construction, l’automobile,
les plastiques, les céramiques… [inspiration]
Il s’avère qu’avec l’avènement des véhicules
électriques et le développement des pays en…
développement, la demande en ces
minerais augmente drastiquement.
Ces métaux, aujourd’hui on les prélève sur la
terre ferme (pas le choix), mais ça pose pas
mal de problèmes. Sans même parler du fait que
certaines ressources soient concentrées dans
des territoires pas au sommet de la régulation
environnementale, les mines terrestres sont pas
trop un exemple de respect de l’environnement et
des humains. Entre la dégradation des habitats,
la pollution de l’air, des rivières et des
nappes phréatiques, les déchets toxiques,
l’expropriation des populations locales…
Donc bref, si on pouvait trouver une
alternative, ça serait bonard. Et c’est
là qu’interviennent les grands fonds marins,
situés au-delà de 200 mètres de profondeur.
La particularité de ces nodules, c’est qu’ils
sont bien plus concentrés en métaux que les
cailloux qu’on extrait sur le continent.
Une entreprise de minage en eaux profondes
avance que la moitié des moutons de cette zone-là
permettrait de construire un milliard de voitures
électriques, en émettant un tiers de gaz à
effet de serre en moins par rapport au minage
terrestre. Ça se réfléchit.
Et c’est pas le seul avantage du deep sea mining.
Déjà, les grands fonds représentent
60% de la surface de la Terre,
avec plein de minerais potentiels dessus !
En plus, 80% de ces nodules sont situés dans
les eaux internationales, donc ils n’appartiennent
pas à un pays donné a priori. Voilà qui rebat les
cartes de la géopolitique. Et y’a qu’à se
baisser pour ramasser nos moutons en plus !
C’est tentant non ? Je vous avoue que même moi en
lisant ça je me suis dit “ah ouais, quand même…”.
Mais avant de nous emballer,
regardons de plus près d’où viennent
ces minerais et comment on les extrait.
A commencer par nos moutons. Ces moutons
se forment dans les plaines abyssales par
précipitation de métaux contenus dans l’eau de mer
autour d’un petit noyau : un bout de coquillage,
une dent de requin, une arête, un os de dodo
que Noé a mangé pendant sa traversée. Faut
dire qu’il devait trouver le temps long, et
puis c’est tentant aussi quand on vit dans
un énorme garde-manger qui flotte.
Et donc, par couches concentriques,
les nodules grandissent au fil du temps,
gentiment posés sur le fond marin. Faut
pas être pressé par contre, on est sur quelques
millimètres de croissance par million d’années.
On estime que nos champs de moutons s’étendraient
sur l'équivalent de la superficie de l'Asie.
Certaines zones sont très riches en moutons, comme
celle-ci, au milieu du Pacifique, qui focalise
l’attention des Etats et des industriels.
On l’appelle la CCZ ou zone de fracture de
Clarion-Clipperton. La quantité de manganèse,
nickel et cobalt rien que là dépasserait
la totalité des réserves continentales
connues. Oui, c’est à ce point-là.
Maintenant, la question, c’est comment on
peut extraire ces moutons qui sont parfois
à plusieurs milliers de mètres de profondeur
? Eh bah déjà, il me semble que c’est plus ou
moins en cours de réflexion, mais ce sera un
sacré défi technologique dans tous les cas. Il
va falloir que les engins supportent des
différences énormes de pression, température,
densité, salinité et pH. Ce sera pas du gâteau.
Tout ça se fera sans doute avec des machines
contrôlées à distance, on va pas descendre des
mineurs mineurs à 6000 mètres de profondeur quand
même. Les industriels sont pleins d’humanité.
L’idée pour ramasser ces nodules, c’est d’avoir
3 éléments : un aspirateur qui se balade
sur le plancher océanique pour slurper les
premiers centimètres de sédiment, où
se trouvent les nodules, un ascenseur
pour ramener tout ça en surface, et un bateau
qui triera les nodules du reste du sédiment,
lequel sera rejeté en mer. Dans un contexte
commercial, il faudrait ramasser plusieurs
milliers de tonnes de nodules par jour pour
être rentable. C’est énorme, et potentiellement
les impacts environnementaux aussi.
D’abord, comment vont réagir les bestioles
abyssales quand on va leur sucer l’habitat
dans un roomba géant? Eh ben probablement
que c’est la fin mon ami pour tous les organismes
du fond qui croiseront la route de l'aspirateur.
Mais c’est pas tout, parce que outre la
dégradation de l’habitat et la pollution sonore
et lumineuse du chantier, ça va aussi remuer du
sédiment. Et notamment quand les machines vont
rejeter après traitement l’eau et les déchets
dans l’océan, plus ou moins près du fond.
Et ça, c’est catastrophique
pour plusieurs raisons.
Ca va créer un panache de sédiments,
comme une tempête de sable, qui peut
retomber en pluie sur les fonds marins
et ensevelir les bestioles qui avaient
tenu bon jusque là. Vous avez survécu à
l’aspirateur, essayez Pompei maintenant.
Mais c’est qu’une partie des particules
qui vont retomber, les autres pourraient
rester en suspension dans la colonne d’eau
pendant des années et sur des dizaines,
centaines voire milliers de kilomètres. Du
coup, l’eau va se troubler et on fait un bon
gros fuck aux filtreurs comme les éponges qui ont
besoin d'un milieu transparent pour vivre. Tant
pis aussi pour les organismes qui communiquent et
chassent à vue comme les espèces bioluminescentes.
Mais c’est pas fini. Ce panaché- euh
panache ne contient pas que des sédiments,
il peut aussi porter des métaux (ceux-là même
qu’on a remués pour les récupérer), vous savez,
le cuivre, le cadmium, le zinc, le plomb, eh bah
ils sont toxiques pour la vie marine. Et eux,
ils pourraient rester en suspension dans
la colonne d’eau pendant des siècles !
Des siècles pendant lesquels ils
vont pouvoir contaminer voire
décimer les organismes vivants,
et remonter gentiment la chaîne
alimentaire jusqu’à par exemple le
poisson dans nos assiettes. Miam.
Et y’a la température aussi ! Parce que
cette eau qui ressort après traitement
va être réchauffée (c’est pas voulu, c’est
juste les machines qui émettent de la chaleur
en triant le bon minéral de l’ivraie), à tel
point que cette eau pourrait être 10 degrés
plus chaude en sortant qu’en entrant. Vous
imaginez l’impact que ce sauna peut avoir
sur des créatures marines habituées
à des conditions extrêmement stables.
En plus que c’est pas trois palourdes qui
vont être chatouillées par l’aspiro. Des
scientifiques ont justement étudié la zone
CCZ dont on a parlé, et 70 à 90% des espèces
trouvées étaient inconnues jusqu’alors. Ils y
ont trouvé des poulpes, des poissons, des coraux,
des crinoïdes, des organismes unicellulaires
de parfois 5 cm de long… Donc ces zones qu’on
aimerait bien raser, non seulement elles
sont habitées, mais en plus elles pourraient
abriter une faune à la fois abondante et
diversifiée. Un peu comme nos aisselles.
En fait les chercheurs se sont même
rendu compte que plus y’avait de nodules,
plus y’avait de vie, avec certaines espèces de
coraux qu’on retrouvait que sur les nodules.
Mais ces écosystèmes sont encore très mal connus.
La rumeur dit qu’on connaît mieux la surface de la
Lune que le fond de nos océans. Donc difficile
de prévoir les impacts possibles du minage si
on sait même pas à quoi ça ressemble ni
qui y réside et comment ça fonctionne.
En fait, la question la plus importante,
c’est : est-ce que ces endroits peuvent
se remettre vite si on exploite ces
champs de nodules ? En d’autres termes,
quelle est la résilience de ces écosystèmes
? Eh bien ça tombe bien que vous me posiez
la question parce qu’on a un début de réponse
grâce à des expérimentations qui datent d’il
y a respectivement 20 et 37 ans. Les
chercheurs ont simulé le passage d’un
engin de ramassage des nodules et ont regardé
comment ces zones se remettaient après. Ca,
c’est la zone témoin, où l’aspirateur n’est pas
passé, et là c’est 37 ans après qu’il est passé.
Dans la zone Dyson, y’a moins de nodules,
c’est normal ils ont pas repoussé en 40 ans,
mais surtout y’a beaucoup moins de bestioles
qui y vivent, et elles sont moins diversifiées.
Les scientifiques se sont particulièrement
intéressés à la faune qu’on retrouve sur le fond,
qu’on appelle épifaune. Et leur constat, c’est
qu’il y a 70% de bestioles en moins qui nagent
près du fond et 8 fois moins d’organismes
accrochés par terre. Donc oui y’a une
sorte de recolonisation dans ces zones, mais
c’était mieux avant. D’après les chercheurs,
les écosystèmes des plaines abyssales
pourraient mettre des dizaines,
sinon des centaines d’années à se remettre
du passage des aspirateurs géants.
Donc
visiblement, extraire des nodules polymétalliques,
ça viendrait avec un sacré prix pour les abysses.
Heureusement pour nous, les plaines ne sont pas
les seuls endroits où on trouve des richesses
minérales dans les grands fonds. Suivez-moi,
on va visiter une source hydrothermale !
Rien à voir avec Evian ni Vichy bien que ce soit
mon régime préféré. On les appelle aussi fumeurs
noirs et fumeurs blancs. Imaginez des geysers,
mais au fond de l’eau. Ils se forment quand il y
a des volcans sous-marins, notamment au niveau des
dorsales, là où le plancher océanique se crée à
partir de magma remonté du sous-sol. En parlant de
plancher, dans ces zones, comme ça bouge beaucoup,
le fond marin est scarifié de failles comme
les poignets de votre petite sœur emo. Et
ce qui se passe, c’est que l’eau de mer va
s’engouffrer dans toutes ces fissures. Là,
elle va se rapprocher magma sous-jacent, elle
va se dire “ouh là là il fait chaud quand même”.
Et au passage, elle va devenir acide sa mère et
arracher des minéraux à la roche adjacente. C’est
ces minéraux métalliques qui nous intéressent.
Puis, Pschitt, l’eau ressort en geyser et ces
précieux métaux dissous vont précipiter
pour former les cheminées des fumeurs,
ou bien ils vont retomber en pluie tout autour
et s’incruster dans les boues qui recouvrent
le plancher océanique. Les cheminées et les boues,
c’est ces dépôts riches en cuivre, zinc, plomb,
arsenic, cobalt et même or et argent, que les
industriels veulent miner. Les petits coquins.
Aujourd’hui on peut trouver plusieurs dizaines de
mètres de couches de dépôts comme ça qui
s’étendent sur de toutes petites zones,
la plus grande source hydrothermale connue
est 14x plus petite que le Vatican. Et le
pire c’est que j’ai trouvé cette info telle
quelle dans une étude, j’ai rien eu à faire.
Des petites zones mais nombreuses
puisqu’on en compte pas moins de 300,
et certaines d'intérêt économique. L’une d’elles
contiendrait 15 millions de tonnes de minerais,
elle est située du côté de la ride océanique
Juan de Fuca. En Français, Jean de fuck.
Alors, comment on extrait ces bidules ?
Eh bien ce sera facile de répondre parce que ça a
déjà été fait. Par les Japonais en 2017, ils sont
descendus à -1600 mètres au large d’Okinawa
et ont prélevé une poignée de ces sulfures
polymétalliques juste pour goûter. Ce qu’ils
ont fait, c’est un dispositif assez similaire à
l’extraction des nodules. Sauf qu’ils ont utilisé
plusieurs machines sur le fond marin pour détacher
les dépôts métalliques et les broyer, puis ils
les ont acheminés en surface grâce à une pompe et
stockés sur un bateau. Et évidemment, tout ce qui
n’est pas intéressant est rejeté en mer. Panache
turbide et mon count es acabat. Donc globalement
les mêmes impacts que pour les champs de nodules.
Le hic, c’est que ces sources hydrothermales
sont des oasis de vie. Oui, je parle bien
des geysers de fluide acide porté à 400°C et
bourrés de sulfures et de métaux. Vraiment,
la faune qui s’est développée là-bas
c’est Chuck Norris avec des nageoires.
On se demande même si la vie sur Terre ne
serait pas apparue dans ce genre d’écosystèmes,
donc ils sont extrêmement importants
notamment du point de vue de la recherche.
Les scientifiques ont déjà découvert
plus de 500 nouvelles espèces autour
de ces sources hydrothermales. Du poisson,
de la crevette, de l’escargot, des vers,
des bactéries, comme un plateau de fruits de
mer à Noël. En plus y’a pratiquement pas deux
communautés de fumeurs qui sont pareilles.
D’un côté de l’océan c’est des collégiens
en manque de popularité, de l’autre des
intermittents du spectacle en sarouel,
y’a de tout. Certains scientifiques
avancent même que 85 % des espèces des
fumeurs pourraient être endémiques, donc qu’on
les retrouverait qu’à un seul endroit sur Terre.
Mais c’est pas parce que ces espèces se sont
adaptées à des conditions de vie ultra hardcore,
qu’elles survivent dans le noir complet dans une
eau si chaude qu’elle ferait bouillir d’envie des
Panzani et qui ont carrément inventé un autre type
de métabolisme basé non pas sur la photosynthèse
mais sur la chimiosynthèse, qu’elles peuvent
pour autant survivre à une grosse perturbation.
Changez leur morning routine, privez-les de leur
soufre du matin et ils seront peut-être en PLS.
Surtout si vous détruisez leur maison et la
broyez en petits morceaux sous leurs yeux.
Les bons points, parce qu’y en a, c’est que ces
fumeurs mettraient plusieurs milliers d’années
à se former et non pas millions donc c’est
déjà mieux que de s’attaquer aux nodules,
d’autant plus que les zones couvertes sont
très réduites donc potentiellement les impacts
de l’extraction pourraient l’être aussi ? Et côté
pollution métallique, a priori cette faune-là est
tranquille puisqu’elle vit déjà dans un bouillon
de métaux toxiques et elle s’y est adaptée,
donc un peu plus, un peu moins… Mais pour
tous les autres impacts, c’est difficile de
prévoir comment un écosystème pareil réagirait,
d’autant plus qu’y en a pas deux identiques.
Bon, donc on a nos nodules polymétalliques
au fond des plaines abyssales, nos dépôts
sulfureux des sources hydrothermales… Et on
a une troisième et ultime source de minerais
dans nos abysses. Une qui va plaire à mon
public lépreux (que j’embrasse) : ce sont les
croûtes polymétalliques. Oui, “polymétallique”
encore, l’océan est plus métal que le Hellfest.
Or donc, nous sommes cette fois sur les monts
sous-marins. Ces croûtes dont je vous parle,
ça se forme comme un glaçage de ferromanganèse,
par précipitation des métaux contenus dans
l’eau sur le socle rocheux, à même notre flanc de
montagne. Un glaçage qui peut atteindre jusqu’à 25
cm d’épaisseur quand même, faut avoir des bonnes
dents. Ils contiennent à peu près la même chose
que nos nodules polymétalliques du début (beaucoup
de cobalt, du manganèse, nickel, cuivre, et même
du zirconium !) et elles se forment tout aussi
lentement (de l’ordre du millimètre par million
d’années). C’est dans le Pacifique qu’on en trouve
le plus, surtout dans le Pacifique Nord puisque
c’est là que la croûte océanique est la plus
vieille sur Terre (160 millions d’années !) et
donc là que les croûtes polymétalliques ont
eu le plus de temps pour se former et grandir
sur la croûte océanique. Ça fait un sandwich de
croûtes cette histoire. Un sandwich de croûtes
fort intéressantes parce que on a estimé qu’elles
abritaient par endroits 4 fois plus de cobalt, 3,5
fois plus d’yttrium et 9 fois plus de tellure que
l’entièreté des réserves continentales connues.
Pour prélever ces minerais, on sait pas très
bien ce que les industriels ont prévu de faire
vu que les infos sont pas publiques, mais dans
tous les cas ça va pas être facile de décoller
les croûtes de la roche vu qu’elles sont cimentées
dessus. On sait pas s’ils vont y aller au burin ou
s’ils préfèreront leur faire écouter du Orelsan en
boucle jusqu’à ce qu’elles décident elles-mêmes de
s’en aller, mais dans tous les cas y’a fort
à parier que si des bestioles habitent sur
ces croûtes, elles feront pas long feu.
Bon, mais si c’est difficile à choper,
on peut au moins espérer que ces croûtelles soient
désertes, non ? Eh bien que nenni ! Les monts
sous-marins sont carrément des hotspots
de biodiversité. Eh ouais, pas de bol.
Ils sont couverts de récifs de coraux, d’anémones
et d’éponges et qui abritent près de 800 espèces
de poissons, avec aussi des requins, des
thons, des tortues, des cétacés, des crustacés,
des mollusques et des oursins et étoiles de
mer. C’est un peu la scène de “sous l’océan”
dans la Petite sirène. Ces écosystèmes-là sont
les plus mal connus des trois dont on a parlé,
mais certains chercheurs avancent que 80%
de ces espèces pourraient être endémiques.
Et côté résilience, me direz-vous ? Eh ben c’est
mal barré. Déjà, faudra attendre des millions
d’années pour que nos croûtes repoussent. Et
côté biodiversité, comme finalement, l’extraction
minière ressemble un peu au chalutage profond,
des chercheurs se basent sur des expériences de
chalutage dans les monts sous-marins pour imaginer
les impacts potentiels de l’exploitation minière.
Et il s’avère que les traces du passage d’un
chalut se voient encore 10 à 30 ans plus tard,
donc on peut s’attendre à la même chose avec
une opération de minage. En plus, la faune y
sera probablement complètement différente après,
puisque les communautés qui peuplent les monts
sous-marins sont des espèces qui vivent longtemps
et qui grandissent lentement. Par exemple,
certains coraux ou éponges sont séculaires voire
millénaires ! Donc quand l’espace est brutalement
rasé, déjà bah, elles crèvent, et ensuite il
est très vite recolonisé par d’autres espèces
plus réactives et tant pis pour les pépés et
mémés, ils avaient qu’à être plus rapides.
Faut bien garder en tête que là je parle
d’impacts potentiels. Pas des effets
avérés parce qu’on n’a jamais miné les fonds
à l’échelle industrielle encore, je le répète,
c’était toujours que des tests. Et en plus on
connaît pas très bien les techniques qui seront
utilisées. Et on connaît si mal le fonctionnement
de ces écosystèmes que c’est difficile d’évaluer
les impacts de cette activité. Mais en tout cas,
les impacts potentiels qu’on a mentionné ont été
identifiés par des scientifiques,
qui sont tous relativement unanimes.
Mais y’a pas uniquement les effets que j’ai
mentionnés plus haut qui sont à craindre.
Certes, on a parlé de la destruction des habitats,
certains ayant mis des millions d’années à
se former, des panaches turbides de sédiments
avec une potentielle contamination métallique,
des pollutions sonores et lumineuses des engins
qui travailleront potentiellement nuit et jour,
en affectant toutes les bestioles marines et
pas que celles du fond, y compris les mouettes.
Mais c’est pas fini ! Le meilleur pour la
fin. Si on remue tout le sédiment joyeusement,
ça peut aussi relarguer le
CO2 séquestré dans les sols
océaniques depuis des millions d’années. C’est
pile le bon moment, on en manquait du CO2. Et
empêcher l’océan profond, en particulier les
plaines abyssales et les sources hydrothermales,
d’accomplir son rôle de “puits de carbone”,
en perturbant les communautés de microbes
qui normalement fixent ce carbone en décomposant
les joyeux cadavres qui tombent au fond de l’eau.
Alors peut-on faire du deep sea mining durable
? Vu les temps de formation de ces ressources,
ça risque pas. Et même s’il y en a potentiellement
des bons gros stocks qui nous permettraient de
voir venir pendant un moment, elles ne sont
pas renouvelables (à l’échelle humaine en
tout cas). Mais les métaux qu’on mine sur
terre non plus, c’est pas le but du truc.
Et côté impacts sur les écosystèmes
marins, de toute façon ce serait
impossible d’avoir zéro impact. Et on part
de loin quand même avec le minage terrestre,
donc est-ce que ça peut quand
même pas représenter du mieux ?
Concernant l’impact socio-environnemental,
toutes les études ne sont pas d’accord entre
elles. Certaines affirment que le minage
des abysses est sans doute moins coûteux,
ne serait-ce que parce que tout se passe
sur l’eau donc pas besoin de construire des
infrastructures ni des routes en déforestant
et expropriant gaiement, et qu’en plus les
bateaux pourraient être réutilisés après. D’autres
chercheurs avancent que pas du tout et qu’une mine
en mer consommera plus d’énergie et génèrera
plus d’émissions que son équivalent à terre,
bref difficile de conclure, d’autant
plus qu’on connaît trop peu les grands
fonds pour estimer vraiment tous les impacts
d’une activité qui n’a pas encore eu lieu.
Et s’il y a un accident, sur
terre ça peut être catastrophique,
vous vous rappelez peut-être de ce barrage
brésilien qui a rompu en 2016 et a répandu
50 millions de mètres cube de boue et de
déchets toxiques, a tué 19 personnes et
interrompu l’accès à l’eau potable de centaines
de milliers d’habitants. Mais on voit qu’en mer,
quand y’a un accident ça peut aussi
prendre une ampleur inattendue.
Bref, je suis assez d’accord avec ces
chercheurs qui écrivent en 2018 : “les
coûts économiques élevés de l’impact
écologique du minage terrestre sont
souvent utilisés comme un argument en
faveur du deep sea mining. Pourtant,
cette approche de “pas à côté de chez moi” qui
les pousse vers les fonds marins violerait le
principe de précaution pour lequel les Etats se
sont accordés pendant le Sommet de Rio en 1992.”
Le truc c’est qu’en plus, on peut craindre un
effet pervers. C’est pas parce qu’on va miner
dans les océans qu’on va pour autant arrêter
de miner sur terre et toujours dans les mêmes
conditions. Donc au final, ça pourrait juste
augmenter les stocks de métaux disponibles
c’est-à-dire augmenter beaucoup plus vite
l’offre que la demande et en conséquence,
très probablement faire s’effondrer le cours
des métaux, sans qu’y ait pour autant de progrès
sur le plan social ou environnemental
là où y’en aurait besoin. Coup dur.
Bon, maintenant que vous savez pourquoi on
s’intéresse aux grands fonds et pourquoi
c’est peut-être pas la meilleure idée d’aller
extraire leurs richesses, il reste une grande
question : pourquoi on en parle maintenant ?
Et pour y répondre, j’invoque Raphael alias
underwaterbaguette sur instagram, biologiste
marine et militant contre le deep-sea mining.
Qui va nous raconter des bonnes nouvelles, et
c’est rare en environnement, faut en profiter.
La semaine dernière, à la COP27, Macron a affirmé
que la France soutenait l’interdiction de “toute
exploitation minière des fonds marins”. Cette
position va donc encore plus loin qu’un moratoire,
qui est une pause temporaire, demandée
par les scientifiques. Et pour une fois,
c’est pas que de la poudre de perlimpinpin
: les paroles ont été suivies d’actes.
Quelques jours plus tard, aux négociations
de l’Autorité internationale des fonds
marins - l’autorité chargée de réguler et
d’encadrer l’industrie minière en haute mer,
au passage soupçonnée de conflits d’intérêts avec
les entreprises minières - la France a concrétisé
sa position auprès des autres Etats Membres. C’est
une position diplomatique forte qui positionne
notre pays aux côtés d’Etats comme le Costa
Rica, le Chili, le Panama, la Nouvelle-Zélande,
l’Allemagne ou l’Espagne, qui appellent à
un moratoire ou une “pause de précaution”
sur cette industrie étant donné le manque de
connaissances scientifiques sur les écosystèmes
abyssaux et l’absence de réglementation
suffisante pour protéger l'environnement.
Mais le combat est loin d’être fini. Il
faut à présent ramener d’autres pays dans
le sillage de la France, pour bloquer le début
de l’exploitation des fonds marins. En effet,
la lutte contre le deep sea mining est
une course contre la montre depuis qu’une
entreprise minière canadienne, The Metals
Company, a déclenché une loi dite la “loi
des deux ans”. Cette loi oblige l’Autorité
internationale des fonds marins à délivrer
les premiers contrats d’exploitation minière
deux ans après son activation, soit juin 2023,
et ce peu importe si un cadre réglementaire
existe ou non. Et puisque les scientifiques
nous disent qu’il nous faudra des décennies pour
comprendre les impacts environnementaux du deep
sea mining, il sera impossible d’avoir
un cadre réglementaire strict d’ici la.
Et c’est pas des blagues : les premiers
tests à large échelle ont déjà eu lieu.
En septembre dernier, The Metals Company
a obtenu une autorisation pour récolter
3600 tonnes de moutons polymétalliques. Les
annonces récentes de la France pourraient
donner de l’élan au mouvement anti-deep
sea mining qui grandit de jour en jour.
Merci underwaterbaguette, si vous aimez la
biologie marine et les dessins précipitez-vous
sur son compte instagram. Raphaël est aussi
membre du collectif "LookDown" qui lutte
contre cette industrie aux côté d'ONG comme
la SOA et d'activistes comme Camille Etienne,
donc pour vous tenir au courant des actualités
autour du deep sea mining, vous savez où aller.
Moralité, on va avoir de plus en plus besoin
de métaux dans les années à venir. Est-ce une
bonne idée d’aller les chercher au fond
des océans ? C’est pas bien sûr. Miner
les écosystèmes abyssaux s’avèrerait
extrêmement invasif et destructeur,
qu’il s’agisse des plaines abyssales
et leurs nodules polymétalliques,
des sources hydrothermales et leurs dépôts soufrés
ou encore des monts sous-marins et leurs croûtes
polymétalliques. Mais conséquence inattendue, le
deep sea mining pourrait aussi avoir un impact sur
la régulation du climat par l’océan.
Quand on pense que certains de ces
minerais serviraient à développer
l’économie “verte”, c’est cocasse.
Une autre idée, plutôt que de chercher à extraire
toujours plus de ressources, ça serait de mettre
l’accent sur la sobriété énergétique et de
développer l’économie circulaire pour recycler
au max les ressources qu’on a déjà extraites.
Certes, on aura toujours besoin de métaux,
mais y’a ptet moyen qu’on en recycle un paquet
pour limiter notre impact sur l’environnement.
En tout cas, s’il y a un truc que les études que
j’ai pu lire martèlent, c’est qu’il faut plus
de recherches avant de faire quoi que ce soit. A
ce jour, moins d’un millième des abysses ont été
explorés.) Donc avant de s’approprier des
ressources millénaires voire millionnaires,
qui ont en plus une signification culturelle ou
spirituelle pour certaines populations humaines,
essayons d’explorer ces endroits, d’apprendre à
les connaître, comprendre comment ils fonctionnent
et protéger les zones les plus fragiles
avant de risquer de leur faire du mal. Ce
serait ballot de faire disparaître des espèces
avant même qu’on les ait découvertes, non ?
C’est l’heure de la page réclame. Merci
à Cambly de soutenir cette chaîne !
Imaginez, vous êtes sur scène en train
de dispenser votre éminent savoir à une
poignée d’heureux élus avec toujours la
très grande modestie qui vous caractérise,
quand soudain, dans le public, quelqu’un
prend la parole et vous demande de traduire
en anglais ce que vous venez de dire en
français. Tout le monde vous regarde et
attend. Imaginez un peu. Heureusement, ça
n’arrive que dans les rêves ces choses-là.
Bon, c’était un peu approximatif mais j’étais
contente de pas avoir perdu mes moyens,
déjà. Une pensée pour les traducteurs qui font
ça toute la journée et qui, eux, le font bien.
Bref, je pensais pas que ça allait m’arriver un
jour. Et pourtant, heureusement que j’étais un
peu préparée. Peut-être que vous aussi, vous vous
dites que ces choses-là ne se produisent jamais.
Auquel cas, je vous présente Cambly ! Cambly,
c’est un site qui vous met en relation avec des
anglophones natifs qui vous permet de converser
en anglais avec eux. Les tuteurs viennent de
plein d’endroits différents, ça permet de
se faire l’oreille, on peut même les choisir
selon leur accent. Il y a toujours des tuteurs
disponibles à toute heure du jour ou de la nuit,
7 jours par semaine. Donc si à un moment vous avez
une envie soudaine de parler anglais à 3h du mat’,
c’est possible. Vous vous connectez sur le site,
vous choisissez votre victim–euh votre tuteur,
et roule ma poule. Vous pouvez aborder
des thématiques précises, par exemple
pour se préparer au Toeic, à un entretien
d’embauche, un examen, une présentation orale,
ou bien simplement tailler le bout de gras pour
parfaire son anglais courant, par exemple avant
un séjour à l’étranger. Parce que l’anglais
écrit, c’est bien mignon, mais y’a que quand
on commence à pouvoir tenir une conversation
avec quelqu’un que ça devient un peu sérieux.
Et non seulement c’est bien, mais grâce à
moi c’est encore mieux ! Si vous cliquez
sur le lien en description de la vidéo,
vous disposez de 15 minutes de cours
gratuit sans engagement pour essayer Cambly
en discutant avec le tuteur de votre choix,
mais en plus bénéficiez de 60% de réduction
sur votre abonnement de 12 mois ! J’ai bien
dit 60 ! Economisez plus de la moitié du prix
de l’abonnement ! Le lien est en description,
n’hésitez pas à vous balader sur le site pour
voir à quoi ça ressemble. Et merci à Cambly
de soutenir cette chaîne et de vous permettre
de devenir imbitabl– imbattable, en anglais !
Merci d’avoir suivi cette vidéo,
merci aussi à underwaterbaguette
pour sa participation et son gros coup de
main pour la biblio, quel homme. On se voit
très vite pour un sujet un peu plus joyeux et
d’ici là… J’aurai trouvé une phrase de fin.